السبب الرئيسي
بالحكم على وائد الدوله السعوديه الاولى
هو انتشارها وتوسعها واخذ مكانتها
الطبيعيه بحيث ان الدول الكبرى مثل
بريطانيا وروسيا فرنسا الدوله العثمانيه
اصبحت تخاف على مصالحها في هذه المنطقه
فهذا الهدف
وحد بينهم
وزودوا الدوله العثمانيه والجيش المصري
باعتى واحدث الاسلحه الحربيه التي
استخدموها في تهديد هذا عكس ما يشيعه بعض
نسميهم مثقفين وما ادري ايش يعني من
تيارات قوميه واسريه عربيه انه دوله
السعوديه الاولى هي صنيعه انجليزيه او
غربيه بالتالي انت انت من واقع دراساتك
تقول يعني كيف موضوع الاسلحه وش تقصد
بالاسلحه استاذ
فرنسا زودت جيش ابراهيم محمد علي باشا
بمدافع باحدث المدافع التي يمتلكها الجيش
الفرنسي وباحدث بنادق القنص
وزودتهم ايضا برومات فرنسيين فرنسيين
منهم في سينار مهندس هو المهندس شاركوا في
الحمله وهم المخططون للهجوم على الدرعيه
اعرف كيف وكانوا ركن اساسي في جيش ابراهيم
باشا من حيث الاستشارات وتنفيذ
الدوله لماذا لان الحكومه الفرنسيه خشيت
من التوسع الحاصل للدوله السعوديه الاولى
واخذ دورها كدوله اصبحت لها مكانه عالميه
مستقله
وشريكه اساسيه في صنع القرار الدولي انذاك
وليس صنع تابع مستقل مستقل
اصبحت الدوله السعوديه الاولى بقوتها قوه
مكافئه لفرنسا وروسيا والدوله العثمانيه
نفسها فلذلك تامرت عليها هذه الدول
للتقليل من او القضاء على ثقلها السياسي
والاجتماعي والعسكري وديني بالاضافه ان
الدوله السعوديه الاولى اصبح لها انصار
حتى في الهند حتى في بلاد الشام حتى في
مصر نفسه حتى في فرنسا اصبح لها انصار
وموالين لماذا بسبب الاثر الايجابي الذي
انعكس على حياه الناس من العدل المساواه
الرخاء الاستقرار والامن واصبحت الدرعيه
انذاك
قبله للناس اصبحوا الناس يهاجرون الى
الدرعيه للعيش بامن وامان
وبكرامه وبرفاه وايضا اشاره الانجليز
دكتور
مشهوره رحله الكابتن سادلير نعم وهو كابتن
مبعوث من الطرف البريطاني لتهنئه ابراهيم
باشا بعد ان احرق الدرعيه
وارتكب ما ارتكب هناك فذهب اليه وحاول ان
يقابله في الدرعيه هذا الكتاب منشور ثم لم
تسعف الحظ قابل في الحناكيه قرب المدينه
هذا الخبر ذكرته في كتابي بطولات حصار
الدرعيه وبطولات السعوديه عندما تمكن
ابراهيم باشا بسبب عوامل عديده من دخول
الدرعيه واحتلالها انا لا اعتبر انه ان
دخول الدرعيه سقوط هو احتلال من احتلال
الدرعيه بدات بدا ملوك
كبريات الدول العالميه بتهنئه محمد علي
باشا بهذا الانجاز الذي
كان كانوا يخافون من توسع ونفوذ الدوله
السعوديه الامام محمد بن سعود اصبح صاحب
قرار محلي واقليمي ودولي ثم الامام عبد
العزيز ثم الامام عبد العزيز